there is more to life than just
breathing
there's more there there is more between
heaven and earth that is dreamt of in
our materialist philosophy
i think finally some people are waking
up
there was a video that went went viral
yesterday of some people in a restaurant
they're sitting around
they're having having a nice meal and in
walk the health inspectors and the
health inspectors want to shut down this
business
want to shut down people having a good
time they are the enforcers
of the state religion of secular
scientific progressivism
and you will comply you will obey and
the people in the restaurant they say
no thanks g-t-f-o
um
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect way to handle it if you couldn't
hear at the very beginning
the woman says hey um so you're
trespassing on my property
and you need to leave my property right
now man the cajones on that woman
if if even a fraction of the squishy men
in this country had the gullions that
that lady has
we would be in a much better place as a
society
and then all the people in the
restaurant get out get
this is how all of these health
inspectors
should be greeted when they walk into
private places
i'm not saying we go full maxine waters
here i'm not saying
you get up on them and you mob them and
no i'm not saying we do that
i'm saying that you very forcefully very
confidently very assertively and
determinedly
tell them to get out they are not wanted
there
i don't think you should physically
intimidate them i don't think you should
mob
up on them but you should be crystal
clear you don't care what they think
i don't i ser i'll speak for myself i
don't care what they think i don't care
what the health inspectors think
i don't care what dr fauci thinks i am
not going to abide by their unreasonable
guidelines which more and more would
seem to be mandates
with the binding force of law even
though they seem to be passed through
really bizarre means
not through the traditional
constitutional order
and that you're not going to listen to
them if if even a quarter of the people
in this country
had the clarity and the courage that
those people in that restaurant had
the country would be reopened but
unfortunately
we're in a country with a bunch of
neurotics who don't have
the same kind of gumption that a lot of
these people do
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]